the jurgen experience don how did you
when when did you you you started out
was like ufc eight
was that your first fight noah's first
in the ufc
yeah boxing and kickboxing before that
right no kickboxing i did
boxing um i think i had eight fights
and um i think i was
two and six or two five and one i don't
know because
i fought my first two is don fry and i
won those
and then i had an argument with
my trainer and so we split
and then so then i fought under
jrfry why'd you change your name well
that was my name growing up as a junior
so jr
and that's how i was in you know junior
high high school
and then um you know what my dad
mom called me and then i think i changed
my name because
of uh contractual you know oh you had
some deal with the manager
yeah right there's a lot of those sneaky
deals huh
yeah but um that was more the trainer
and
you know i don't know if that was
because they were really good guys
uh art mart tori was my money guy who
you know they they the two munoz mike
munoz and his father al brought me to
art art wrestled at asu
back in the late 60s and art
uh he's a billionaire you know and so he
was in
interested and i mean he he basically
funds asu wrestling
oh really yeah oh that's nice half his
pocket yeah
and he's done so much for amateur
wrestling
in the us i mean he's like the top dog
because he used to have what's called
sun-kissed
wrestling team uh so that was his baby
and he steamrolled that and
um then like i said uh
the munoz brothers or mike and his dad
took me to art or so i just give it a
shot
after he called um
geez the coach at oaky state
um jose to double double check on me you
know
so did you started out wrestling did you
wrestle
as a young boy no sir when did you start
wrestling
uh as a freshman in high school
and then when did you box uh when i got
out of college
oh so uh most of it was you know that's
fairly late in life to box right
oh yeah oh yeah that's why i was two and
six so when did you hear about the ufc
um i was a fireman you know i just
did the boxing and then got out did
started doing odd jobs for you know a
year year and a half
and uh then my
wife at that time we had a couple horses
you know and being a collie dresser you
got a bit of an eagle when you
so i don't get well hell i could do that
so
uh still going around with a farrier
named
stoney newfang and then stoney got me
interested then
i um got tired of that
wasn't really making good money but you
know for the time he's giving me five
bucks a horse
you know teach me you know pull the
shoes
um shape the shoe you know and all that
good stuff
well he he did the technical work on the
hooves
and then um i said
you know somebody told me about being a
fireman about
you know working 10 days a month
you know and wrestling i said hell
that's the job for me you know
10 days a month i can do that you're
doing the 24-hour shifts
you stay there at the firehouse yeah
yeah so i got on the phone
called up all the cities in the city
arizona nobody was hiring
so i called up santa fe new mexico
they said yeah we're gonna run a test
and so i went over there and tested
and passed the test and then i went to
uh my buddy jerry packetball he's
got me into wrestling um when i was
in high school come over here later
please
so i wouldn't stay at jerry's house in
santa fe and i went through their i
think it was like a
six month or more
um academy you know in the fire
department
yeah really six months yeah wow it was a
hell of an academy
it really was and so from there you
thought about fighting
no i had already fought no but i mean in
the ufc oh no
um from there we were there a year year
and a half
couldn't afford to live there you know
you know in santa fe you're either real
rich or real poor
you know this is 30 years ago so i don't
know how it is now
but um probably similar probably
like the whole country now right yeah
it's supposed to be nice though santa fe
a lot of people good friends from there
beautiful yeah you never been no never
been oh you gotta go
i don't even think i've been in new
mexico except driving through once
really yeah
where'd you drive through it i was a kid
i don't remember it yeah
yeah you didn't obviously you haven't
gotten through see
uh john jones no no jackson winkle john
i want to go down there and check out
the gym though
how come you haven't she's just a busy
man don fry just a busy man
so when you when you first heard about
the ufc
so you were a firefighter then or well
back to the back to the half yeah you
know like i said we were in
santa fe for a year year and a half and
then couldn't afford to live there
and uh so i got on the phone
and said well [ __ ] you know we still had
horses
and still paying farrier so oh [ __ ] i
could do that so
i found oklahoma horseshoeing school in
oaky city
and so i moved my wife back home
to my parents house you know and i went
to
oklahoma horseshoeing school for their
12-week program
oh wow and so i did that and then when i
came
back to uh arizona sierra vista
um hooked up with a guy named um
oh jesus um
tyler basinger tyler is a magician
as a farrier just a magician
and he paid me five dollars a horse you
know
and fed me lunch and uh
and you know so i was learning how to
shoe horses from him you know do an
apprenticeship
start my own business i got on as
a firefighter reserve you know
the place called fry fire department
yeah fry
no relation is the old man uh
had a outpost store outside of fort with
chuca
you know 150 years ago and also a
whorehouse
this is like old-school western [ __ ]
yeah wow
and so then i then i had some time i
worked at a um
psych facility too you know site
facility
psychological oh psychological facility
yeah what'd you do there like
restraining patients
yeah yeah what's harder horseshoeing
or restraining patients we're sure i
broke a kid's arm so
you know just the headlocks you know
they
they did a breakout where you know 20 or
30 of them run off and then you got to
hurt them back in
and really boy a couple of them act out
and
one of the guys had the kid restrained
for he
had him from behind had his arms pinned
kids started slamming his head into his
face
so i just walked up to the headlock and
we landed
snapped his arm oh no yeah that kind of
kind of put a damper on things yeah was
that the end of your restraining patient
[Laughter]
so how does it make its way to the ufc
do you remember when you found out about
the ufc
yeah then i think that was still
a year or two before so this is like 92
something like that yeah and then um
i started doing judo you know because i
needed
you know i needed something to do you
know right
uh you know you're 22
24 years old you you know you used to be
a college athlete yeah you know
you still walk around with an erection
right i understand
and um so i started doing judo
and advanced really quickly in that
and um you know
so then then we're i got on the bisbee
fire department
in 94. arizona
yeah yeah shout out to doug stanhope
he's the king of bisbee
yeah that's what i hear i met him one
time
yeah at the uh airport oh yeah yeah he
says
you're a firefighter it used to be this
[ __ ] this was probably
15 18 years ago oh wow
and um yeah we're the helen arena so you
were talking about
when you first heard about the ufc yeah
in 92 i got on with the bisbee fire
and then we were sitting there watching
something on tv and saw dan clip a dan
dan severn uh-huh and uh then he was
doing
some kind of bodyguard work for robin
from
um who's a radio guy in new york robin
quivers
howard stern right oh really no [ __ ] it
was a great t-shirt yeah
wow everybody says sushi dance is a
great t-shirt
and so uh they you know then we saw dan
fight
and i called him out and said [ __ ] you
know i said dan
don fry remember me yeah what are you
doing donna's just
playing fireman playing horseshoe you
know
can you say this ufc stuff can you get
me in on it and he says yeah
so he ended up getting me some fights
probably about five or six fights you
know around the country
and uh you know check's still in the
mail you know
um was this pre-ufc yeah yeah oh so you
fought mma before the ufc
oh it was it was warehouse fighting yeah
by the mma
isn't it right right so right and hp is
what they called it back then yeah no
holds barred right
so you wear shoes you do whatever you
want it was a bare knuckle
yeah yeah in your day and even in the
ufc eight it was you're still allowed to
fight bare knuckle
yeah yeah but i wore gloves because i
hit heart
yeah you know yeah and smart gloves are
made
to protect your face right they may
protect my hands
who's the first guy to wear gloves in
the ufc was it tank
yeah smart smart move he hits hart
yeah um holy [ __ ] i remember your fight
with tank what a [ __ ] fight that was
my god you know and it didn't make uh
top 10 of the one-round fights
oh i don't have no idea why it doesn't
well it's because there's so many great
fights it's arbitrary who makes top 10
but i think it should have been in there
that was a classic nobody knows nobody
knows anything about ufc 100 and b of
war you know
i do you do you know and you were there
i was there the new fans yeah they
should go back because
that's that's the history of the sport
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience